10 peut-être que je vaux compte deux à
huit parcelles de ba vi à travers
quelqu'un dos des gens en 2017 c'était
lavogez souhaitait donner un sens à sa
maladie
la sclérose latérale amyotrophique pour
elle c'est vraiment elle allait de soi
que tant qu'à demander la mpq alla
mourir elle allait faire le don
d'organes sa fille a fait d elle une
grand-maman deux fois plutôt qu'une
l'été dernier c'était la vorace décide
que le temps est venu de mettre fin à
ses souffrances
choisir de faire un don d'organes
signifie que l'aide médicale à mourir se
fera forcément à l'hôpital c'est la fin
et fabre aussi d'accommoder la cob de 19
est donné elle voyait que ce n'était pas
le bon moment et là c'est comme si elle
avait ajusté s'adapte au début septembre
pour que l'on soit entre les deux vagues
puis pour être le moins contraignante
possible pour le système juste passé à
l'humanité de cette femme ne s'abîme
transplant québec juge maintenant que
les patients qui demandent l'aide
médicale à mourir doivent savoir que le
don d'organes est une option pour eux
ont refait le prélèvement vraiment aussi
proche de la personne
dès que possible donc ça prend le
docteur avec un bloc opératoire
videmment cette nouvelle catégorie de
donneurs aura un impact positif
moi je suis convaincu que ça va faire
une différence parce que il y aura une
proportion de plus en plus élevé de gens
dont ce n'est pas contre indiqué qu'ils
vont souhaité le faire début septembre
martin st-louis s'est donc retrouvé avec
sa mère à l'hôpital sacré car on nous a
permis d'abord des chandelles des photos
on a mis de la muse la musique qu'elle
voulait
et au final qu'est ce qu'un regard des
faits l'intérieur de nous de nos yeux
avec peu importe environnement physique
dans lequel on était gelée senti quitter
or nous regardons nous l'infirmière
marie claude prudhomme le maire était
auprès de la famille peux vous dire que
j'étais avec sa fille de fer l'hôpital à
la fin car on a vu les policiers
passaient pas ses yeux qui transportent
les organes alors on a un sentiment
d'accomplissement de preuve n'est un peu
son désert à terme on ne sait pas qui
les a reçus on ne peut tout serait très
confidentiel mais on sent vraiment que
on a fait la différence
800 québécois attendent une greffe le
nombre de donneurs au québec tourne
autour de 140 par année
le don d'organes dans le cadre de l'aide
médicale à mourir est passé de 2 en 2010
est à 13 de l'an dernier la contribution
de stella est d'autant plus précieuse
qu'on prévoit une année creuse en 2020
li programme de transplantation ayant
été mis sur pause pendant la première
vague ici anne louise despatie radio
canada montréal